welcome everyone
uh my name is anita winfield from
nanostring marketing
it is really my pleasure to open today
now the special answer trilogy
there are three events the first one
today focused on
oncology second one tomorrow focused on
immunology
and in today's time on tuesday it we
have the special answers
focus on neuroscience research
so the event is sponsored by nanosecond
illumina and with the great scientific
support
of the eacr before i introduce our
speaker
in our chair most of all for today
i want to remind everybody that this is
a live webinar
you can post and we encourage you to
post your questions
on the button on the left of your screen
the question and answer
box and we'll answer them i will strive
to answer them all
at the end of the presentations as i
said we are live but you can also watch
this presentation recorded as soon as we
finish
it will be available on demand
let me just introduce now our chair
today
professor juan celane group leader
and director of the translational
research program
at the vas de bruyne institute of
oncology and professor of the autonomous
university of barcelona
one will share this session today is the
secretary general
of the eascr association and will take
us through the presentations and the
questions and answers and has a great
announcement
later on to make two over to you who are
now
thank you
all right thank you very much uh
anessa it's a fantastic
opportunity to to be in this session i
think it's going to be a fantastic
session
but before starting this session today i
want to pre-announce
that we are going to open a new spatial
profiling grant
today and we will give you all the
details after the speaker's
uh presentations uh so
please stay tuned uh to the end and you
will learn
about the whole transcriptome in situ
eicr grant
for your ffpe and fresh frozen samples
so today we will start with two short
presentations five minutes each from
ruby from nanostring and anna from
illumina
who will share some brief information
about the technologies
that are used by our presenters today
so
okay let's go uh with the first one
thank you juan for the uh for the nice
introduction um
so i've been giving the difficult task
uh to present to you
and give you an introduction in spatial
biology in just
five minutes so my name is rudy van
eisen i'm the manager of the
product application scientist team at
nanospring technologies
um and um well i'll get started
explaining about spatial biology in five
minutes
so if you would look at nanostring's
website look at the
over 4 000 publications and do a search
you'll see that 1700 publications are in
some way related to the development or
validation of
signatures so that's more than 40 of the
total publication
a number um so people have been using
the nanostring technologies
in in some way to discover
and validate biomarker signatures and
bring them into declining as well most
of them is using both gene expression
analysis
sometimes even with with great
technology it it's difficult to find the
right biomarkers
and this is illustrated very well with
this publication which is a
collaboration with nanospring and merck
where they have identified a genus
expression score a t-cell inflamed gene
expression score
also known as the tumor information
signature
which is associated with progression 3
survival and also
is somewhat predictive of response to
treatment however
in this in the plot on the right side
you see that
there are quite a bunch of patients that
have a high
tumor inflammation signature score but
still do not respond very well to
treatment
and there are reasons for that so why is
that gene signature not performing very
well
it's all due to heterogeneity of the
tissue
so here on the left side we see a hot
tumor and on the right side as well
because they both have
high tumor inflammation signature scores
however on the left side and on the
right side we see differences
with respect to immune cell infiltration
and that could be the reason
why one of these patients typically the
one on the left is not responsive to
treatment
so this is a very interesting aspect so
if you would do bulk gene expression
analysis on this
you would not find those differences
because because it would all
level out and in the middle of this bulk
grind and buying dashi
it's also illustrated by this more
schematically if you have responders
non-responders
if you would do both you get similar
gene expression profiles
however if we would allow you to focus
on specific parts of the tissue
you might see differences making it
easier to find the right biomarkers
while doing that looking at spatial
information it's always a trade-off if
you go spatial
you need to give in on flexing so the
number of targets that you look at
if you go higher plaques you very often
have to give give up on the spatial
information
secondly there's always a trade-off and
quantitation
and precision so we believe that with
the nanostring geomets digital spatial
profiler
we can make life a lot easier and it has
already been proven
because at this point there are already
over 45
peer-reviewed publications not in the
least type of journals
we have some covers as well that you can
see on the left side
clinical cancer research nature madison
all the big journals as well
so let me explain you in a few slides
how the technology works before i hand
it over to these speakers that
gives you an explanation how they use
the technology in their research
so the technology is all based on either
antibodies if you want to detect
proteins or nc2 hybridization probes if
you want to
investigate gene expression with spatial
information
in both situations we attach a dsp
barcode which is photocleavable by using
a photoclickable linker so your
uv light will make that bsp barcode
cleave off
the barcode has a unique sequence and
there's one unique sequence for every
individual target that
we want to measure so this is the
schematic workflow so first there's
always a staining of your ffpe or fresh
frozen section
in that staining you will have either
nc2 hybridization probes
or antibodies labeled with the dsp
barcode
on top of that there will be fluorescent
markers
giving you the morphology of the tissue
that's step two based on that morphology
you'll indicate
which regions you want to analyze in
more depth using the panel that we've
chosen
and then we shine uv light specifically
and only within those regions
cleaving off the dsp tags and collecting
them in a
96 well collection plate let me repeat
that for all the other regions of
interest that you've selected
then we'll take that collection plate
and then we can count
the abundance levels of the dsp barcodes
referring to the abundance levels of the
targets
by using either the nanostring encounter
technology
or the illumina next generation
sequencing
for counting in the end for every region
of interest
on every sample and then sometimes you
can split up the regions of interest
in different segments different
compartments within the tissue
you get digital caps presented in a
table like that
which is then subsequently imported back
into the geomex dsp software
connecting the data back to the spatial
location
so this way you can detect different
types of targets
rna and protein you can use it on
fresh frozen and ffpe tissue so you're
really looking at the spatial biology of
different
tissue types if you if you want and it's
optimized it's proven by all the many
different publications out there already
so these are just listing the advantages
and i'm sure the next speakers will
illustrate those
thank you for your attention
hello everybody my name is ana babayan
and i'm cancer research marketing
manager at illumina
and i would like to give you also some
insights on the sequence inside of the
things
so thank you again for joining and
welcome to
another co-host webinar with another
string and illumina
spatial analysis brings together the
world
of histology and sequencing allowing us
to study human biology
at unprecedented depth and high
resolution
this is done in situ on tissue sections
which allows us to interrogate a tumor
complex biology in the context of its
micro
environment by by um
bearing i'm sorry the resolution power
of nanostrings geomixed spatial
technology with the luminous
leading next generation sequencing
readout we can look at thousands of
genes on the same tissue slide
these cutting edge technologies are
available now
and are posed to revolutionize cancer
research
high throughput sequencers provide a
large menu of applications
critical for cancer research from
profiling of the tumor and its
microenvironment
using rna sequencing at the bark and
single cell level
as well as immune profiling using tcr
sequencing and protein detection to
analyze commonly utilized cell surface
protein markers
and mutational profiles of the tumor
using whole exome sequencing
and whole genome sequencing by
partnering with another string we are
now adding
another powerful tool to cancer research
of cancer research to this growing list
and i think i'm experiencing some bad
connection
issues so i'm gonna switch off my camera
just to
save some bandwidth for um
to present my slides so all our
sequencing protocols
whether you are interrogating dna rna
protein or epigenetics
ah whether you decide to do any of those
at bulk single cell and using spatial
interrogation
basically consists of those four highly
integrated steps
sample preparation as you can see on the
screen which is decay
which is in the case of spatial analysis
consists of standard tissue sectioning
protocols
the next is library preparation
where illumina sequencing adapters are
added and subsequent
sequencing and also analysis have been
made simple
and accessible as part of the workflow
because of eliminate sequences data
quality quality and throughput
aluminum sequences provide the readout
with which you can sequence up to
18 000 gene from a single tissue slide
interrogate
the section at dozens of locations
within the sample
and analyze dozens of samples in one
sequencing run
whether you decide to sequence on the
highest throughput sequencer
the novasic on the right or on our
newest mid throughput sequencer than
nexic 2000
you can count to consistent data quality
and the ability to analyze data across
omics
and resolution
what we offer is quite a bit of
flexibility and choose your sequences
depending on the amount of
sequence and content you would like to
interrogate you can interrogate
over 1800 genes simultaneously
with spatial resolution using
nanostring's cancer transcriptome atlas
or upscale your analysis with more than
18 000
protein coding genes with the whole
transcriptome atlas from nanostring
and you can also add protein detection
to look at
known treatment for markers this is true
multi-omics on a slide
in addition to further streamline the
workflow in march we just announced
public availability
of nanostring geomix digital spatial
profiling
with dragon on base space sequencing hub
read more about this workflow on our
blog post
so today you will hear about nanostring
and illumina's combined spatial solution
spatial biology is poised to
revolutionize our ability to interrogate
super biology
especially in a time when the
understanding of the contribution of
very complex human
environment is continuing to provide
novel molecular targets for therapy
prognosis predictive biomarkers and to
diagnostic biomarkers as well
and spatial analysis and spatial
multi-omics
is already providing actionable insights
and some of which
we will hear about today and thank you
for your attention thank you very much
rudy and anna very clear and
very very concise which is very good so
the next
uh is going to be a a short
talk from professor noel de miranda
he is associate professor at the leiden
university medical center
he's principal investigator of the
cancer immunogenomics
research group at the department of
pathology of the leiden university
medical center
his group develops work on several
aspects of cancer immunology and
genomics
with a particular focus in colorectal
and pancreatic cancer
the group's translational aims encompass
identify cancer-specific antigens that
can be targeted by immune therapy
elucidate potential of immune cell
subsets
other than t cells for immune therapy
exploitation
and the possibility of
understanding and mapping up out the
complex and multicellular nature of
anti-cancer immune responses
thank you very much uh noel uh whenever
you want
thank you evan for the kind introduction
i hope you can all hear me
uh well um good afternoon everyone
i'm very excited to show you some
preliminary work
that we have been performing on gene
expression spatial profiling
to reconstruct colorectal cancer tumor
genesis
so i'm actually a pi of the of the
immunogenomics lab so our focus
is slightly different from what i will
show you today
most of our work is is based on the
detection of antigens that are driving
antiturn immune responses but also the
characterization of the complexity of
tumor microenvironments
but throughout the years we developed
quite some expertise
in spatial proteomics and genomics
and thereby we became very interested in
making use of the geomets tools
from nanostring as you might be aware
and this is true for most cancer types
the survival of colorectal cancer
patients is pretty much dependent
at the stage of which a tumor is
diagnosed meaning that if the tumor is
diagnosed at an
early stage where there's minimally
invasive disease i'm not metastatic
the prognosis of a patient is much
better than the one of a patient that is
diagnosed with cancer that has spread to
other organs like
in stage 4 disease so
national health care systems across the
world have tried to address this
by implementing early screening programs
in the hope uh that one diagnosed with
cancer at earlier stages and thereby
uh the clinical management of those
tumors
uh is facilitated so in the netherlands
since 2014 um everyone over 55
years old is invited to perform a
piccolo called
uh blood tests and as you can see on the
graph on the right we saw a huge
increase in the incidence in the
diagnosis of colon and rectal cancer
after this test is implemented which
probably means an anticipation
of diagnosis that we're going to be done
uh
in later years but what's very
interesting and you can see here in the
second graph below is that
when diagnosis is done via population
screening
the proportion of cancers that are
diagnosed at
advanced stages at stage four
it's much lower than
in patients that do not undergo the root
of population screening
showing that population screening really
works
um in in terms of anticipating diagnosis
and
facilitating treatment
of colorectal cancers however this
change in demographics of coral cancer
accentuates other problems which i would
like to discuss with you on the next
slide
so if you have a minimally invasive
cancer let's say a t1
colorectal cancer you can be offered
endoscopic treatment rather than a
full-blown surgery
which involves much lower risks and
causes
less morbidity but if after
clinical intervention unfavorable
histologic features are found or for
instance if you have positive resection
margins
um then the patient is recommended to
to to undergo surgery after surgery
however
uh it becomes apparent uh that
uh metastasis are in fact only found in
in ten percent that patients that
undergo surgery
um so there's a
there is quite a lot of room uh
to reduce the amount of surgery that is
offered to these patients
on the other hand there are also
patients um that are not recommended for
surgical procedures and that are just
treated by endoscopic procedures
and those do show tumor recurrences
at a later stage and we do not have good
biomarkers really to identify the
patients
that are required uh to have surgery and
the ones that are just
really well off uh with the endoscopic
procedure
so just to reiterate that uh what we
need really is good biomarkers that
inform
on the risk of metastatic disease
and we thought that the geomets approach
which allow us to
to assess gene expression across
different regions of tissue
was really a great tool to address this
question
and we thought that on top of having
this translational question this was
also a great
opportunity to redefine models of
colorectal cancer
onset and progression
at the transcriptional level so
we apply the the geomets cancer
transfer tome atlas which which
basically interrogates the expression of
uh 1800 genes related tumor biology
tumor microenvironment and the immune
response
on eight different uh t1 tumors that
were
obtained by endoscopic submucosal
dissection of the department of
gastroenterology of the leyden
university
uh medical center and within each tumor
we selected
nine different regions that corresponded
to
regions of healthy mucosa uh transition
regions
uh between healthy mucosa and dysplasia
low-grade dysplasia high grade dysplasia
and regions where there was very
clear invasive cancer
this to interrogate how this gene
expression
whether we could detect specific gene
expression alterations
across these uh these different
histologies
um and the very important detail which
is
which is essential uh uh to refer
is that the with the geomets platform we
were actually able to interrogate
separately epithelial and thermal
fractions
and we did this by employing a
antibodies mark with
with fluorescence with fluorescence
that bound to pankeratin and to vimentin
and keratin marks epithelial cells
and vitamins and mark's thermal cells
and we were able to direct
uh the acquisition um uh
of the specific acquisition of these
regions so that we could interrogate
gene expression separately
in epithelial uh and thermal fractions
so in fact for every region of interest
and i told you that we did nine regions
of interest for eight different tumors
for every region of interest we keep
distinguished gene expression profiles
in the epithelial fraction and in the
thermal fraction and of course in the
epithelial fraction
is where a tumor cells are in the
context
of colorectal cancer so we have employed
the ums suite analysis suite for
quality control normalization uh
plotting of quality control and
normalization parameters
but from then on we exported the data to
actually do our own analysis in our
and this project is being spearheaded by
jessica roulands
a postdoc in the immunogenomics
group so in this slide i'll just show
you how
how these different samples separate or
distribute themselves in the high
dimensional space
according to the overall profiles
of gene expression and what you can
already appreciate is the near perfect
separation
uh of stromalum epithelial fractions
which is not really surprising of course
because they comprise completely
different types of cells
but it really gives you confidence uh
that the method
is working uh as you expect
um but when looking deeply and what's
really interesting
uh to see is that you also have a
separation
that largely agrees with the annotation
that was made
by histology so normal and transition
samples are are close together in the
middle of the
tsne plot while there's also a
separation according to the degrees of
dysplasia
or whether a region comes from
an invasive area of carcinoma and
to really strengthen the the argument
that the biology makes sense we we
overlay the enrichment scores for genes
involved in wind signaling
and indeed we see a nice increase in the
expression of wind signaling related
genes
as we move to the extremes of the tsne
plot
in line of what it would be expected
regarding crc biology
and the involvement of wind signaling in
cancer progression
so this is another way in which we have
visualized the data and this is the
unsupervised clustering
of the epithelial fraction alone based
on the expression of all genes
and what you can see is that all normal
samples clearly cut cluster away
from the remaining samples and that the
majority
of genes actually decrease as you have
as you observed a malignant
transformation
and something similar is that is also
observed for the vitamins in positive
fractions so the stromal fraction
and what i find it really interesting to
note is that at the moment
we have the feeling that as a whole the
gene expression
patterns or differences observed
in the thermal fraction appear to
provide a better separation
of the different histologies than the
epithelial fraction
and this could be explained by the fact
that is
there is large heterogeneity between
cancer cells that are
derived uh from different patients
but it begs the question on whether we
can actually define biomarkers of tumor
progression
not in the cancer cells themselves but
in the stromal cells that are
associated uh with the cancer cells
so in these volcano plots um what you
can see again is the differential gene
expression stepwise
as we progress from from normal tissue
to
carcinoma and as expected there are
small differences
between normal mucosa and transition
areas and that is the graft
on the left but very interesting
because in in theory these are the
initiating events
of tumerogenesis of course but once you
really move into areas of dysplasia the
differences become huge between
mythologies
and this can be seen again in both
epithelial and stromal fractions
so as i alluded before a lot of the
biology
makes sense uh which makes us very
confident on the on the methodological
approach so we see a gradual increase
in the strength of wind signaling as we
progress into myrogenesis
in both epithelial and thermal fractions
but also in other pathways uh like
epithelial to to mesenchymal transaction
and which is very closely associated to
the activation of tgp the signaling for
instance
and this is really pronounced in the in
the stromal fraction
of the tumors but also when comparing
invasive cancer
with other histologies
and this is of course very exciting
because
with the current approach we know that
we can identify biological mechanisms
known to be involved in cancer
progression in crc which really
validates
uh the approach but what's most exciting
is that we found
several other pathways that behave in a
similar manner
as i showed you for the wind signaling
pathway and for the emt pathway
where you see an increase in activity of
this pathway in both fractions
both epithelial and thermal fractions
but pathways that were not previously
associated with colorectal cancer
progression and we're currently
investigating
uh and validation validating those and i
hope that we can share
those with you soon so so far i showed
you
uh pathways that behave in a largely
concordant manner
between epithelial and thermal fractions
of the same tissue and this makes sense
right because a lot of these pathways
they're regulated by growth factors that
have a paracrine function as well
so if a tumor produces a certain growth
factor it will not only
impact tumor cells but it will also
impact uh thermal cells that are
regulating that are
um that are surrounding the cancer cells
but i want to to zoom here on two
examples of two pathways we found to be
differentially regulated
um in the epithelial and the stromal
fraction
so in the first pathway which we call
pathway
m what we see is the profound
upregulation during tumor progression
uh in this thermal fraction but hardly
any changes in the epithelial fraction
and if any uh in the opposite direction
well for pathway d we see an increase um
in the epithelial fraction during term
progression which is not mirrored
uh into thermal correction and these
results really
really beg the question whether um
whether we would be able to to pinpoint
uh these processes as being associated
to tumor genesis if we had analyzed
these samples
by bulk rna sequencing for instance
where the contribution of
of the transitional profiles
in both fractions would probably uh be
averaged
i would just like to to briefly uh
mention one very interesting potential
application of this undertaking
uh which is the easiest to translate
would be to identify individual
biomarkers
uh that can assist in the discrimination
of healthy tissue from cancer
and which could for instance be used as
therapeutic targets
or biomarkers that assist in endoscopic
or surgical procedures
and indeed we identify
in both uh epithelial and perhaps even
more pronounced
uh in this normal fraction variations in
gene expression
that are strongly associated with
malignant reformation
and which we are currently uh
validating um so then the next steps
uh for us will be to to we'll we'll
spend
quite a amount of time at validating
what we found at gene expression level
to see if it translates a protein level
but also a very exciting component of
this project is the intersection of this
data
with multiplex protein data that we have
generated with imaging mass methodology
and we are particularly interested in
exploring the possibility
to deconvolute the thermal
expression signatures back to the cells
that are composed in that
all components so this
was what i had to show you thank you
very much for your attention
i would just like to mention uh these
people
which are involved in the project and of
course funding
from the erc md ldmc and i will be happy
to answer your questions later
thank you so much uh noel uh fantastic
talk
uh very very well done um i'm
i'm going to ask the audience to make
questions
uh and we will answer them together with
the second speaker
uh at the end of the second speaker
presentation
but now we will run a poll
so you should select from your screen
the appropriate answer
and we will share the results with the
with you all
shortly so
i will give some some minutes for this
okay and now we can move uh for to the
to the second
talk uh our presenter is basilis extra
strawberry medius
he is a medical doctor uh who complete
completed his
junior surgical training in oxford and
london
he holds two post graduate degrees in
molecular medicine and mathematical
statistics in
from the imperial college and the
university of london
and is currently completing a phd on
prostate cancer
at ucl under officer
mark emberton professor caroline moore
and dr
hayley whitaker in
2018 he was awarded a clinical research
training fellowship
by the uk medical research council for
here
for his research which aims to explore
the association between prostate tumor
microenvironment inflammation and mri
phenotypes
commonly see in scene in the prostate
uh thank you so much vasilis the floor
is yours
thank you very much for the very kind
introduction uh hello all
i'm gonna hopefully share some exciting
preliminary results from
our work with namaste in the next few
slides
the title of the talk is a
transcriptional evolution of
radiologically progressing prostate
cancer
you know already a little bit about my
background um
because it was this was finally provided
in terms of prostate cancer
uh we do know now that it's one of the
most common cancers in men
its incidence is increasing and that's
primarily due to the
fact that uh awareness is increasing and
also that the
introduction of process-specific antigen
testing
in the last three decades has basically
led us to
detect a lot more cases in
recent years until fairly recently
the mainstay of treatment for prostate
cancer was
surgery or radical protect or radical
prostatectomy that is or some form of
radiotherapy
that was applied to the whole prostate
in later stages
the treatments consisted of chemotherapy
and the administration of hormones
in in recent years however these
landscapes have slightly changed there's
now more modern
uh treatments and some alternatives for
very specific types of prostate cancers
which we'll see
uh shortly the important thing
in diagnosis is obviously certification
of risk at baseline
and that is traditionally done using a
set of variables
uh the tnn stage the psa level
uh the the cancer grade measured the
by the gleason grade which is is
gradually being supplemented supplanted
by the grade group
classification um and basically with
using these variables we can divide
roughly prostate cancers into those
that have a relatively low risk and
therefore pose
a low threat to the patient in terms of
the cancer specific mortality
intermediate and high risk
cancers um
this is an important uh exercise
clinical exercise
and um particularly because uh there is
preliminary evidence from previous
decades that actually
there are some prostate cancers that
exist within the prostate will never
cause any problems
during a man's lifetime and there are
others that actually
are more likely to progress evolve and
cause cancer-specific mortality and
those are the ones that need to be
treated
and basically particularly recently
it wasn't that easy to differentiate the
two but
clinical developments diagnostic tests
and
other in clinical awareness as well
actually led us
to a situation we have to define uh
those two different types and also we
have to be
able to differentiate them when we are
comfortable
with a particular patient and this is uh
truly important because as you can see
the more aggressive and high risk the
cancer is
the more it departs mortality and it
also
it impacts um the um recurrence of
the cancer after it's been removed on
the left you see a very famous paper by
a figure from a paper by j epstein
european urology showing
how the more hyristic cancer is then the
high
there is the probability of biochemical
recurrence after surgery
and on the right there's some data from
the very famous protect trial
showing that if you actually operate or
treat
with radiotherapy cancers that are most
significant
your actual survival in terms of cancer
prostate cancer specific survival
doesn't substantially change
there is uh some improvement in the
metastasis free survival but the actual
role is cancer-specific survival the
post-account specific mortality does not
change significantly
so as clinicians we diagnose impossible
cancer is not enough
we have to know which positive cancers
are significant and which are not
and that's something relatively specific
to the oncology of the prostate uh
in other tumors we need to know uh we
need that muscle
as early as possible but uh simple
diagnosis on its own in the prostate
cancer context is not enough we have to
know whether the cancer is actually
worth treating and this is where uh
active surveillance is a very exciting
established uh
new way of actually managing those
tumors that we diagnose but actually are
not
we're not very convinced that they do
need treatment imminently
this essentially is a strategy where we
monitor the patient over a
period of time we perform regular tests
process specific antigen tests sometimes
biopsies
and we defer treatment until and unless
there is evidence of disease progression
that essentially means that we can
monitor patients over a long period of
time
but we can only intervene when it is
necessary
we are actually confident that the
cancer is actually more likely to lead
to a
an adverse outcome surveillance cohorts
are now
maturing there is some dropout from a
lot of them
primarily due to disease progression but
there's also some
non-adherence primarily due to the fact
that um a lot of
standard active surveillance protocols
now
involve repeat biopsies and obviously
men
avoid repeat bites as much as possible
so there is a little bit of dropout from
that as well
um the problem with standard sampling
process sampling when we actually put a
needle into the process to do a biopsy
is that
like i mentioned the first problem is
that the men don't like having too many
of those
and the second one up until fairly
recently was that the
way that we did the biopsy and the
process was fairly random so we just
deployed
the the needle in um a few parts of the
prostate
without actually having any information
beforehand as to how we should direct
that needle in the prostate and
or whether there are specific areas we
should be focusing on
and what that did is essentially
introduce a little bit of a
bias in our um characterization of a
given prostate
and in the surveillance context as a
context as we
saw that that could be detrimental
because what you don't want is to
classify a high-risk tumor as low risk
and put mental surveillance
this is where a multi-parametric mri has
changed management of prostate cancer
very recently
by doing some imaging prior to biopsy
you can actually
focus on suspicious areas in the process
there are more likely to be significant
cancer
and sample those much more efficiently
at the same time to kind of reduce the
uh over diagnosis of those insignificant
foresight of
a tumor that you do not really want to
treat or
aren't very unlikely to harm the patient
in the long run
um this is a slide again reiterating
what i just said
um that uh mri has basically now
revolutionized that most prostate cancer
it's advocated by the
most associations in europe and the
united states
and at the same time it uh it appears
that it could be a very useful tool
uh for monitoring process tumors that
are on surveillance
those are significant tumors or
intermediate with tumors that we can
actually monitor over time and defer
treatment for
and what it mri does it it appears that
it doesn't just improve certification of
diagnosis
that we just said and therefore the
improves the selection of vacuum
surveillance candidates
but the other thing it does is actually
can
reduce the need for multiple biases
during surveillance by
because we can use a non-invasive method
to actually monitor tumors across time
imaging based uh cohorts are now quite
uh
they exist all over the world one of
them existed ucl recently described
uh by one of our papers as you can see
here and
we have found that the the more visible
the prostate cancer is at baseline the
more likely it is
uh for that patient to
leave surveillance early and basically
get treated earlier compared to other
men
who do not have silica visible this is a
baseline
we in those kinds of types of cohorts we
can actually
monitor tumors and then only
uh intervene and resample them when
there is radiological progression
we do not yet know exactly what
radiological progression
is or what it's attributed to and how we
can properly define it and the
european school of oncology precise
criteria aim to do just that to actually
some give some definition and structure
when we are monitoring tumors over time
with mri
to say okay which uh changes progression
then we need to be careful about it and
which is
probably just a normal variation over
time
but we do know that mri phenotypes are
associated
typically with microstructure of the
tissue where
we're looking at so therefore could we
have a an idea of what's happening
within an mri lesion
a cancerous mri lesion as it progresses
over time
here for example on the left you can see
the image of a significant process
cancer
that is on surveillance and on the right
you can see the same cancer
after dilutive progression you can see
that
the glands are more crowded and tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes are actually
[Music]
entered the scene and this is where
um perhaps um the other thing you can
see is actually
this this increase in cellularity poster
geological progression
and obviously all these changes can be
um tracked back to some kind of
molecular
mechanism and this is where the cta uh
for mana string
can be quite useful in terms of the
grant itself the process that was very
easy
uh they we had um
essentially tumors from um men who
um whose whose cancer was sampled before
and after ideological progression
this was a ffp samples uh we sent a
slide to nanostring um use the workflow
that was briefly mentioned
and that's the kind of data you would
get back typically
thousands of genes 800 genes from
regions of interest
uh very similar to the previous
presentation you can see that the first
thing to note is that
the the assay could actually
differentiate areas that were benign
from areas that were cancerous um
on the pc april here as you can see they
can very there is a very good
differentiation and separation of the
two
um even the areas
uh where you see some overlap
actually a lot of them were hydrate
dysplasia or areas that were not
entirely normal so overall we could see
that in the differentiation of
benign versus tumor the assay worked
pretty well
the second conclusion is that um
the um the overall sort of gene
signature
in the benign tissue surrounding the
cancer before and after ideological
progression
did not substantially change here you
can see the top 50 differentially
expressed genes
and at the top of the graph you can see
blue for before progression and red for
after progression sample the same tumor
you can see that the atomic landscape
did not change significantly however
when it came to cancer
the situation was quite different you
could now
definitively say that there is
a difference in the atomic profile of a
tumor before and after radiological
progression
so i'm expecting to actually look at
these results in a
bit more depth and actually supplement
it with a a lot of other data
but in short i wanted to give you a
little bit of an idea what nanostream
can achieve
the asset can achieve and basically
present to you the first preliminary
evidence that actually
when you have the same process tumor
sample twice in time
that actually whilst the benign
compartment actually appears to
retain its transatomic profile and
characteristics
the it is a tumor actually that
undergoes the
most profound changes in terms of the
transatomic contextual
um i i could highly recommend
basically using downstream can say it
was a very
good experience the team has been
wonderful in assisting me through the
whole experience
and like i said i'm hoping to shed
further results with you in the future
i'd like to thank
my funders the acr and amsterdam and
obviously
a whole bunch of people but this has too
many to thank so i'll just
pass the floor to the next person
so thank you so much uh basilis
fantastic talk again
so let's proceed now with the questions
um
there are several of them i will ask
the speakers uh i will also ask them to
be short because there are many
questions so
we can go through them uh um
quickly so let's go for the first one um
this is a question for noel
and basilis what was the major advantage
for you to be able to select the regions
of your interest
to dive into and also to look at
different tissue compartments with your
solutions
i can go first um so
for us the major advantage is that we're
very much interested in looking at the
at the cancer cell compartment and the
thermal compartment uh
cyprus believe which also stands for are
interesting
in tumor immunology um
and of course the ability to look at
different tissue compartments allows us
to correlate gene expression changes
uh with specific morphological
alterations that we can see in the
tissue
or that the pathology pathologists can
see
in a tissue to see whether they stand or
if
we get some more information from from
gene expression
do you want to complement uh yeah i
think uh definitely pathology
i agree with noel it's basically
pathology is essential when you do this
discover projects
you want to identify areas of interest
[Music]
and then stratify them according to the
severity of the grade of a particular
tumor
identifying dysplasia for example could
be notoriously hard for the non-expert
so
i would definitely recommend having
pathologists on board the journey
beyond that for us the as you saw the
main thing was to actually
the main purpose of the project was to
actually try to decipher
how the same prostate lesion
evolved over time transatomically and
obviously the needle is never perfect it
goes a little bit to the left a little
bit to the right
so being able to capture all the
heterogeneity from a single sample was
essential to actually
start doing some comparisons because
otherwise if you did bulk
work you wouldn't be able to tell what's
the main driver
behind that trusted atomic change you
see on data
all right thank you so this is a
question
to noel is it possible that population
screening detects
tumors that would never become
clinically manifest
if yes do you have any idea based on
your research which one of these could
be
probably the same discussion applies for
prostate cancer
yeah i mean that's a very good question
but
um it's very it would be very difficult
to predict which tumors we are analyzing
or which ones would be the ones that
that would not
develop into full blown cancer of note
we did only include
uh tumors that clearly show in
an invasive uh portion so clearly
classified st1
but i'm sure there would be a a number
of these tumors that would go with
asymptomatic
um and not be
diagnosed otherwise i'm not really sure
how to test that
[Music]
from from a methodological point of view
though because once we remove it from
the patient we don't know anymore
uh whether that tumor would develop or
not to full blown cancer
yeah so basilis do you want to say
something about this
yeah i think uh like you very correctly
said it's uh i think
with prostate cancer where um it's a bit
of a different landscape in the sense
that you have a blood test that has to
be investigated
so as soon as you sample the tumor then
you have to
make a clinical decision it's a little
bit easier
compared to other malignancies in that
you
you know for example once you see a low
risk tumor that you do not necessarily
have to treat it from using outcome data
but i agree that um
the main thing is that we have a blood
test and the majority of them are
symptomatic whereas in colorectal cancer
unfortunately
you have a disadvantage that a lot of
the cancers are picked up at a
systematic stage so so there is no
option for
survey surveying those and monitoring
those cancers is not an easy
it's not an easy endeavor so um but in
the prostate cancer we definitely have a
problem
over diagnosis we're now picking up way
more
insignificant disease that we would like
and that's where mri basically
is a little bit helpful in reducing that
burden uh
to the to the patient and and the health
care system
perfect let me let me check chip in and
i have also a couple of questions one
one for each of you uh first for for you
and oil
um have you seen differences between
different subtypes of of colon cancer
such as cms
one two three four uh did you did you
found some
differences especially in the stroma for
cms4
yeah so so that's actually something um
we would be very much interested in in
trying it out
um to see if we can translate the
algorithms that uh
that classify uh the cms subtitles
uh across uh the spatial uh
contexture um that's definitely
something on the
on the list um
it would also be nice perhaps to see
whether there's heterogeneity within the
same tissue regarding uh
regarding the molecular classification
and based on
rna expression yeah that's a very good
question and suggestion
all right and and for you basilis
uh i noticed that in your example there
is an increase in
in t-cell infiltration i mean this is
this the one of the difference
you are finding in your cluster that is
increasing cancer
in cancer development do you do you see
more in immune infiltration
uh well that's actually something we're
we're looking to do next
um because you would need ideally to
quantify that somehow and that
objectively came down with um you know
things like uh
multiplex immunofluorescence or uh
actually look at hne images so we're
looking into doing that
uh but it's definitely interesting to
see not just the quantity but also the
qualitative aspects of what kind of
inflammation do you get because you
might get inflammation in the early
stages which might be
associated with the benign or
premalignant process but that doesn't
necessarily mean that
because you see an infiltration later
you say it is the same infiltration
might be different
in other ways and i think that's where
for example anastro could be useful in
deciphering and
decomposing basically exactly what's
going on in
a specific area um in terms of the
benign signal it was it appeared and we
have a very small sample it appeared to
be the same before and after progression
even after the
cancer rate increases but
that i wouldn't necessarily um
[Music]
you know hold on that results just yet
primarily because the sample is small
but even if it were to be true it's very
useful because it points us to the
direction of where we should be looking
so maybe
um expanding the transforming signature
looking at other types of signatures is
also very
clinically useful which we wouldn't have
done without special
special resolving these men so
yes there are plenty of other
applications we can look
into perfect let's go on with the
the questions the other question is
for noel how long did it take you
to generate these great results from
cutting the section and
to getting and analyzing the final
results i guess it's a very technical
question
um i don't know if you want um
yeah i mean we still didn't get to the
final results
um but like maybe the question
is focused a bit more on the wetland
part and the selection and data
acquisition that was actually quite fast
um we planned the session with a with an
answering people and that went very
smoothly it actually took us longer to
organize which samples we were going to
process and get them cut
than acquiring the data but then of
course you get a wealth of data
and you run the risk of being mesmerized
with it exploring all different things
that might be in the data so at some
point we will have to say stop and just
have
and just release it for everyone to to
have a look at it
perfect so a question for basil is uh
do patients prefer mri-based
surveillance over
standard non-imaging non-imaging based
protocols
um it appears that roughly
roughly speaking it appears that they
might do uh i think
uh the as i briefly mentioned in the
lecture the
uh one of the primary disadvantages of
standard protocols that are not imaging
base is that you have to
do biopsies every now and then and a lot
of particles are not quite prescriptive
and obviously men do not necessarily
like that so you do see
a substantial drop um after three and
five years
in terms of their compliance and their
anxiety but if you use imaging uh even
if you
spare them from uh a few extra biases
actually that seems to be to improve the
uh their compliance we have very little
people dropping out at uclh
although it is it is a you know quite
specialist environment but still we
had very few dropouts and it appears
that uh
from my clinical experiences basically
that people are really involved
they like looking at an image they like
look at their tumor and imaging and
seeing how it is they just
they just seem more involved with it
rather than just presenting them with a
pathology report
so that helps um but obviously you know
it would be good to study how
what's a long-term effect of introducing
imaging in this awareness pathway and
see exactly what's going on but the
evidence is
is definitely for it rather than against
it at the moment
perfect and now for you noelle um would
you consider sub dividing the data kiss
reaction process
for additional cellular flux fractions
in addition to keratin
and vitamin d um
yeah so i think
there are a lot of possibilities um
depending on what is in
what you're interested in for instance
we could have thrown into the mix also
an antibiotic against cd45
and further subdivide our fractions into
epithelial
stromal non-immune and immune i think
it's just a matter of having
a good anti antibody and an antigen that
that survives
uh the procedure
all right uh just two last questions um
for you by sillies how often do prostate
cancer on active surveillance
progress radiologically and
pathologically
radiological progression is not a common
event it does happen ultimately to
many men but it's not a common event
when it does happen
the real question that we're confronted
with is basically whether we should
sample that lesion again
whether it's it reflects through
pathological and disease progression
or whether it's just normal variation of
an imaging phenotype over time
and it appears that uh from a very
preliminary analysis we've done is that
roughly two out of three times so about
60 something percent of the time
if you have radiological progression
imaging you will
get pathological progression on biopsy
so mri seems to be
pretty good at picking up those changes
as microstructural changes are
accompanied with increasing grade
cancer grade or the growth of a
particular cancer
and like i demonstrated from the example
that i showed you is that you
you do get a change uh in a transatomic
sort of contextual of the tumor of the
same tumor at two points in time it
changes
um in terms of what genes it expresses
um whereas the surrounding environment
seems to be
relatively stable although very
preliminary data
need to supplement it with lots more but
that's what
that's what i showed for now perfect and
the last question for you noelle
can you say something about the
potential clinical application of a
marker
that you determine to be associated with
cancer progression
yeah so i hinted towards that at the end
of
the presentation um if we can use
biomarkers to help improve staging or
predict the occurrence of metastasis for
instance
that would be great but we also have for
instance in the
in the institute's image guided surgery
departments if you actually find it a
marker that can be translatable
to a probe to be used in image guided
surgery to actually have
a surgery where you're able to remove
the whole
tumor that would be a potential
application another potential
application for biomarker
fantastic thank you so much both of you
it is a pleasure for for me to to hear
you and i think it's
it's been a fantastic session uh on
behalf of eacr thank you for being here
and
and presenting your data and uh
and and now just to finish i want to go
on and
and ask pre-announced uh inform you
about the great opportunity to apply to
the
eacr nanostring and illumina oncology
grant
we will award two winners who will
receive a free of charge
whole transcriptome project for the
human
or mouse tissue ffp of fresh frozen
tissue
we we ran a similar grant last year
and it was very very successful and so
we wanted to repeat uh
open up the abs up to upstairs
submission
from today till the 24th of may at
midnight
the winners will be able to send four
slides of tissue to seattle
where the rnd team will run them
on the go geo mx and next
2000 the winners will receive back the
raw data as well
as the results after data analysis and
of course free of charge and so you can
learn more uh getting into uh the
websites
where you will see all the information
uh
about that and i think it's going to be
shown in the
in the in the in the in the presentation
right now so again thank you very much
for
for this time uh for this uh fantastic
uh
session and and there is also a last uh
poll that i think uh you may
want to uh run and and feel it
and again again thank you all and
and see you next time
thank you
after completing slide preparation which
is similar to ihc or ish
we will put our slides into the tray and
then we will put the tray into the
instrument and load buffer
next we will be ready to enter our slide
records and scan parameters
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a fluorescent image with up to four
colors is generated
to enable selection of region of
interest or roi on this tissue
you as the user can choose these rois
from anywhere on your laptop
geometric profiling allows us to choose
circles
squares or even polygons
this would be a great tool when you have
pretty homogeneous regions
like immune cells and the tumor
segregated within one tissue or across
tissues
in your cohort geometric profiling was
utilized in david grimm's nature
communications article in 2020.
many users can also create rules for
segmenting the rois
this would let morphology of the tissue
determine the
boundaries of the area of illuminations
or aois to enable 100
cellularity for example users can create
tumor and tme segments across a tissue
sample as shown on this example
selected rois are illuminated with uv
light to release barcodes from dsp
probes
and then these dsp probes are deposited
into a 96 valve plate
the release dsp barcodes are prepared
via a standard library preparation
so they can be read out on illumina
sequencers the data can be mapped
especially back to the originating
region of interest
[Music]
samples can now be loaded onto your
illumina sequencer
depending on your experimental design
and the instrument capacity
you can read up to 760 rois from a
single geomex experiment
in a single illumina run here we have an
xc2000
which will allow us to easily read
hundreds of protein or rna analytes
once the task view files are generated
they'll be converted to digital code
counts
and then uploaded back to geometry
instruments
the data analysis screen is divided into
three panes and a taskbar
here we describe the functions of each
pane and the interactions between all
three
this campaign is shown on the left side
and contains
individually resolved stance in the
middle pane
we have our data sets and probe lists
on the right we have our visualization
pane which shows the
various graphs in this case this is our
qc
graph the middle data sets
pane lists all data sets and probe
groups associated with the current study
the visualizations pane is on the right
visualizations are visual
representations of the data set
selected and props selected and the
adjustments applied to the
data set from those probes now i'm going
to open another study
here we can see the data has been qc'd
and normalized
once you normalize the data you can see
in your visualizations pane
different graphs including pathway maps
pathway tables bar graphs correlation
plots
box plots pca flats
trend lines and we can view heat maps
i'm going to end with clicking on a data
point on the data visualizations pane
and you'll notice that roi associated
with it will be zoomed in
on the left pane of the screen
presenting seamless integration of the
images and the digital accounts
thanks for joining our customer
experience lab sessions
you